more Megs massive other monsters and a
lot of jokes that's the approach meg2
the trench takes for the super shark
size sequel but does this Chum of ideas
make sense in the end warning spoilers
for meg2 ahead
in a memorable exchange my King Kong
parody in The Simpsons episode Treehouse
of Horror 3 some familiar characters
talk about how they're all headed
towards the dangerous ape Island
I wish we were going to Candy Apple
Island candy apple Island what do they
got there Apes but they're not so big a
cindely misleadingly named Islanders at
the center of the finale for meg2 the
trench a trio of Megalodons to send on
fun Island a coaster Resort where
everyone's dipping their toes in the
water and enjoying lavish festivities
these vacationers get way more
prehistoric shark action than they'd
ever imagined on top of all that a
kraken also emerges from the
Subterranean domain of the trench along
with a bunch of carnivorous lizards that
can travel on land Jonas Taylor and his
friends descend on the island to help
the populace and use ramshackle weapons
to destroy the underwater creatures
though plenty of innocence and villains
get chomped on in all the Carnage Taylor
eventually kills two of the mechs the
final surviving Beast which is Raising
captivity by Joo Ming Zhang eventually
just swims away presumably out of
loyalty to its Master the day has been
saved and everyone can relax on the
beach
in a bid to differentiate itself from
the original Meg Meg 2 the trench loads
up its climax with tons of Larger than
Life beasties Beyond just megalodons
however much like an ancient shark
eating too many partygoers at once Meg 2
eventually bites off more than they can
chew there's just too much happening in
the finale which leaves an already
disjointed feature feeling even more
slab Dash by the end the camera quickly
Cuts back and forth between various
sharks eating people before hastily
remembering there's also a crackhead in
trying to do too much the finale of Meg
2 ends up serving an abundance of
elements poorly even with tantalizing
Concepts like a showdown between a
Megalodon and a kraken Meg 2 is just
juggling too many plates to flesh out at
zany ideas to their full potential
meanwhile the human element of meg2 gets
lost in all the hoopla the corporate
espionites are dominated the first two
acts of the story gets shoved off to the
side for the climax with main body
driscolli getting quickly killed off in
a moment crimped from Dennis nedri's
demise in Jurassic Park
[Music]
if what you want is a lot of noise a
climax of Meg 2 certainly offers up lots
of Critters and CGI
Jonas Taylor is not a character who
evolves or grows much in either Meg
movie much like various characters
inhabited by Jean-Claude Van Damme and
so many other action stars of yesteryear
he's a vessel to show off the coolness
of a specific actor Taylor was
essentially a physical manifestation of
all the calm-headed authority Jason
Statham can muster he doesn't have any
discernible character flaws at the start
of Meg II the trench with his first
scene in the film depicting him
selflessly trying to stop criminals who
are polluting the ocean from there he
acts quickly whenever there's danger
afoot and tries to act as a father to
youngster Mae Ying Zhang even in the
most Shrine circumstances with all this
in mind it shouldn't be a surprise at
the finale of Meg 2 doesn't offer up any
opportunities for Taylor to grow he's
just as growly and prone to
self-deprecating comedic lines once two
of those big sharks are dead just as he
was at the start of the very first Meg
movie little no doubt for straight folks
searching for any tangible drama within
meg2 But Die Hard Jason Statham fans
will be comforted to see the performer
inhabiting a consistent Persona to the
very last frame of this sequel
in the original the maggot took shocks
to take down a shark jodus Taylor
wounded the film's massive Megalodon
enough to get it to spew out blood that
attracted a swarm of ordinary sized
sharks there's always strength in
numbers and the multitude of sharks were
able to Chow Down on the wounded
Megalodon although Taylor had a hand in
this beats demise he was by no means a
sole reason the monster was destroyed
the original Meg seemed to propose that
forces of nature were the only way to
eliminate a massive animal man-made
technology was truly powerless in the
face of prehistoric Primal power Meg 2
the trench goes in the opposite
direction though this time man-made
devices are the ultimate way of
disposing of massive monsters Taylor
concocts a bomb that Slaughters one of
these animals while another is impaled
on a massive blade that a hero puts in
just the right place even the final
Megalodon is only stopped from munching
down three of The League characters
because of juming's training if the
initial Meg presented a glib vision of
how human intervention could fare in the
face of massive sharks the ending of Meg
II paints so much Rose your picture of
showdowns between human beings and the
prehistoric monsters
it seems like a bevy of massive
underwater beasts isn't enough to
provide a challenge for the protagonists
of meg2 because screenwriters John hober
Eric hober and Dean torgeris also
created a human body to throw down with
Jonas Taylor this foe comes on the
character of Montes played by Sergio
Perez menchetta he's a criminal that
Taylor previously sent to a two-year
stint in prison for crimes committed in
the Philippines years later Montes has
hankering for revenge and has his
opportunity once he crosses paths with
Taylor in the trench even as Taylor and
Company scramble to survive in the
deepest parts of the ocean Montez keeps
serving as a violent thorn in their side
eventually Montez travels to fun Island
for the finale having risen to the
surface he's got a troop of soldiers by
sight and is preparing to have a final
showdown with Taylor though he's the
biggest land-bound threat to Our Heroes
his presence in the climax doesn't
ultimately amount to much Montez and
Taylor face off on appear with Taylor
shooting Montez and drawing out blood
that attracts one of the Megalodons
Taylor proceeds to push Montez off the
pier and into the mouth of the hungry
Beastie of course Taylor can't help but
Capital off with a pun
one of the main differences between the
first movie and Meg 2 is the larger
emphasis on Comedy the Meg was by no
means a serious movie and this comedic
element seems to have inspired Ben
Wheatley and the screenwriters to go
even broader with the humor this is
especially true during the over-the-top
climax it's in this sequence that the
returning character DJ delivers some
very lengthy gags ultimately DJ's main
purpose is to provide some comic relief
to all of the violence and Carnage an
example being the long string of condoms
he keeps in his survival pack this was a
bad idea just a little bit meanwhile
Taylor Zhang and Mark pause for a brief
moment to exchange jokes about bad ideas
for how to take out the Megalodons all
while the beasts are chowing down on
Taurus in the background the heavy
emphasis on jokes oftentimes even more
so than the shark Carnage is clearly a
conscious choice on the part of the
creators perhaps it was done to avoid
drawing unintended loves from Bots drama
however whether or not lingering on
shots of condoms poured out to or could
moments of the satisfying move for a
shark movie will depend on the taste of
individual viewers when an audience says
first meet you Ming Zhang is
experimenting with a state-of-the-art
exosuit it's designed to allow him to
travel to the bottom of the ocean but
given that this technology also gives
him enough enhanced strength to punch
pieces off gigantic cinder blocks it's
clear the EXO suits have a lot of
potential once our heroes are trapped in
the bowels of the trench the EXO suits
are critical to the team and navigating
the sea floor however Beyond this
sequence in the movie they don't play
much of a role in the story this
includes a lengthy finale which sends
everybody to fun Island since they're on
dry land there isn't much use for the
suits meanwhile the enhanced strength
function of this futuristic Tech never
comes into play despite it being a
potentially useful tool when humans are
squaring off against a kraken and giant
sharks the heavy presence of EXO suits
in the initial scenes of the trench
makes it seem like this breakthrough
technology will play a big role in the
film's finale however this ending has no
room to pay off that technological
Marvel
it seems like in the last 20 years or so
every action movie is required to tease
a sequel or at least set up the next
entry in the franchise Meg 2 doesn't
follow that Trend and takes the route of
bringing its story to a pretty
definitive conclusion the end of the
film sees the surviving characters all
resting up on a beach sipping drinks and
Jonas Taylor offering up a toast to
dolphins the only major development is
that DJ now has an Entourage of
beautiful women following him around
after his efforts to save the day of
course a trench does keep one Megalodon
alive which could be a tease for a third
film plus the trench is still around
same for all of the larger than life
monsters residing inside those lingering
elements are the closest thing meg2
offers up a sequel teasers otherwise
this ending is a completely Standalone
Affair but that doesn't mean there's
nowhere to go for more Mega Adventures
after all these movies are based on a
long-running series of novels by Steve
Alton that have now spanned eight
installments additionally books like
Primal Waters have used tropes like time
jumps to keep Jonas Taylor Saga going
though the films use the novels as a
springboard for Original Stories there's
plenty of material from other books in
the series to help stir up ideas for new
movies if audiences show up in droves
for meg2 Warner Brothers will definitely
turn to Alton's books for story ideas
foreign